YOU WILL BE ON "FOX AND FRIENDS"
LATER TO EXPLAIN.
>> JOINING US ON THE CLOSING
SCHOOLS IN NEW YORK CITY
HOTSPOTS, JOE BORELLI.
WE KNOW THESE GUYS DON’T LIKE
EACH OTHER, THEY HAVE THIS THING
GOING ON LIKE THE TWO GUYS IN
THE MUPPETS, THE TWO OLD GUYS
WHO DON’T LIKE EACH OTHER BUT
THE ACT IS GETTING STALE BECAUSE
PEOPLE’S LIVES ARE ON THE LINE.
WHY COULDN’T
WHY COULDN’T THEY COME TOGETHER
JUST THIS ONE TIME FOR A
COHERENT COVID-19 STRATEGY?
>> THIS IS WHAT IT IS LIKE
LIVING IN NEW YORK CITY, YOU
HAVE THESE TWO GUYS PLAYING
DUELING BANJOS BUT ONE HAS A
TROMBONE AND THE OTHER ONE HAS A
HARPSICHORD.
THEY CAN’T SEEM TO EVEN GET ON
THE SAME CONFERENCE CALL SO THEY
ARE EVEN ANNOUNCING ONE THING.
IF YOU READ THE NEW YORK POST
YESTERDAY MORNING YOU WOULD HAVE
SAW NEWSPAPER ARTICLES
HIGHLIGHTING THE TROUBLED SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ARE DEVASTATED
THE BILL DIBLASIO WAS SHUTTING
DOWN THE BUSINESS AGAIN.
IF YOU OPEN TODAY’S PAPER YOU
WILL SEE THE SAME BUSINESS
OWNERS SAYING I DON’T HAVE TO
SHUT DOWN AFTER ALL.
THIS IS NO WAY TO RUN A CITY LET
ALONE ONE THAT IS IN THE MIDST
OF A SERIOUS PANDEMIC.
BUSINESSES ARE SHUTTING DOWN BUT
THE CONSISTENCY YOU SEE OUT OF
BILL DIBLASIO AND GOVERNOR CUOMO
IS REALLY UPSETTING AND SHOULD
BE TROUBLING TO NEW YORKERS
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU THINK OF THE
INCONSISTENCY IN CUOMO’S ENTIRE
STATE OF NEW YORK.
WE HAVE AREAS OF THE STATE THAT
HAVE HIGHER POSITIVITY RATES THE
NEW YORK CITY AND DESPITE
GOVERNOR CUOMO SAYING HE
WOULDN’T SEND KIDS TO THOSE
SCHOOLS THERE ARE STILL SCHOOLS
OPEN IN THE HUDSON VALLEY,
ORANGE COUNTY, ROXY THE LAND
COUNTY EVEN WITH THOSE HIGH
POSITIVITY RATES, MAKES NO
SENSE.
>> IT IS CONFUSING TO PEOPLE IN
NEW YORK AND PEOPLE OUTSIDE NEW
YORK WHO ARE LOOKING AT THIS,
GREATEST CITY IN THE WORLD AS WE
STAND WONDERING WHAT IS GOING
ON.
CUOMO JUST WANTS TO SHUTDOWN
CERTAIN SCHOOLS, DIBLASIO WANTS
TO NONESSENTIAL BUSINESSES TO
CLOSE THE TAKE A LOOK AT THESE
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS FROM
AUGUST, THEY ARE NOT GOOD.
UNEMPLOYMENT IN THE CITY, 16%.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO DIBLASIO
ON WHAT HE’S DOING TO SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THE PEOPLE THEY
EMPLOY?
>> I HAD A LONG CONVERSATION
WITH BILL DIBLASIO THE OTHER DAY
AND I DON’T THINK HE’S HEARING
FROM THE SECTOR OF NEW YORK CITY
THAT IS STRUGGLING TO REOPEN.
HE’S IN A BUBBLE OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE FEARFUL AND WANTS THINGS TO
STAY SHUTDOWN.
HE’S NOT HEARING FROM PARENTS
WHO NEED SCHOOLS TO BE OPEN AND
BUSINESS OWNERS THAT NEED
BUSINESS TO BE OPEN.
I DON’T KNOW HOW MUCH MORE WE
CAN TRY TO GET THE MESSAGE TO
HIM THAT THE ONLY WAY NEW YORK
CITY CAN RECOVER FOR IS CHILDREN
GOING TO SCHOOL AND LEARNING AND
WHERE WE HAVE BUSINESSES
OPERATING AS CLOSE TO NORMAL AS
POSSIBLE.
TODD: IT IS A BROKEN RECORD THAT